Chào mừng các bạn đến với khoa học excel
miễn phí từ cơ bản đến nâng cao cho
người mới bắt đầu được thực hiện trên
kênh YouTube và Excel bài số 8 các hàm
quan trọng khác
trong các bài học trước mình đã làm quen
với các hàm tính tổng Tính tổng có điều
kiện tính tổng có nhiều điều kiện nhóm
các hàm đếm đếm có điều kiện và đếm với
nhiều điều kiện hàm điều kiện ít cũng
như là các hàm xử lý chuỗi và các hàm
Vlookup hát lúc cấp trong bài học hôm
nay mình sẽ học các hàm quan trọng khác
là gì hàm somborac các hàm về thời gian
và hàm index + mét trước khi vào bài học
số 8 mình cùng giải bài tập hôm trước là
bài tập số 7 nhé đấy các bạn sẽ mở câu
hỏi của bài tập số 7 lên
các bạn chú ý nhé khi mà các bạn mở lên
mà nó có cái chữ enable editing này thì
các bạn phải tích vào đây thì các bạn
mới sửa được nhá Đấy mình sẽ tích vào
đây Ok bài tập về nhà của bài số 7 hôm
trước mình có hai cái ví dụ ở đây mình
có gì ạ đây là gì ạ đơn giá theo tuần và
đơn giá theo ngày bây giờ mình có loại
phòng rồi đúng ạ Mình cần xác định là
đơn giá tuần là bao nhiêu và đơn giá
ngày là bao nhiêu đúng ạ thì đầu tiên
mình sẽ làm cái phần đơn giá tuần trước
nhé các bạn sẽ bằng gì ạ Các bạn chú ý
nhé vì cái loại phòng ở đây nó đang được
bố trí theo chiều dọc theo cột này thì
mình sẽ dùng Vlog cấp nhé đấy các bạn sẽ
bằng Vlog cấp các bạn sẽ ấn tag nhé thì
thành phần đầu tiên của cái hàm Vlookup
là giá trị dò tìm đúng không ạ thì chính
là cái loại phòng ở đây đấy phẩy thành
phần thứ hai là bảng giá trị dò thì các
bạn sẽ Bôi đen toàn bộ cái bảng giá trị
giò ở đây phẩy thành phần thứ ba là gì
Là cái cột trả về đây là mình cần xác
định đơn giá theo tuần đúng không Thì
cột trả về phải là cột số 2 để loại
phòng là cột số 1 này đơn giá tuần là
cột số 2 đúng không ạ Đấy phải 2 phẩy ở
đây mình tìm chính xác sẽ là 0 hoặc
false đấy các bạn sẽ không các bạn đóng
ngoặc lại
enter đấy như vậy đơn giá tuần của cái
loại phòng l1a ở đây ấy là 260.000 này
Bây giờ mình sẽ thay cái loại phòng l1a
bằng l1b nhé
nó sẽ ra là 250.000 tương tự với cái đơn
giá ngày thì nó khác gì với đơn giá tuần
thì cái đơn giá ngày thì cái cột trả về
phải là cột số 3 đúng không ạ Nó sẽ
giống hệt với cả cái đơn giá tuần ở đây
các bạn sẽ bằng này Vlog cấp các bạn ấn
Tab nhé Thì Thành Phần đầu tiên là cái
loại phòng đúng không ạ thì mình cần tìm
cái loại phòng l2b ở đây chính là cái ô
F6 này phẩy thành phần thứ hai là bảng
giá trị giò thì các bạn sẽ Bôi đen toàn
bộ cái bảng giá trị giò ở đây nhé Đấy
phẩy cái cột trả về đây là cột số 3 đúng
không ạ Đấy phẩy ở đây mình tìm chính
xác là 0 và phôi nhá Ví dụ mình gõ phôi
đi các bạn sẽ đóng ngoặc đơn lại để xong
hàng Vlog cấp bây giờ các bạn enter nhé
đấy thì như vậy cái đơn giá tuần ở đây
là 30.000 đây Các bạn thấy chưa l2b này
đơn giản tuần là 30.000 Ví dụ mình sửa
thành lập một bên nhé
các bạn enter đấy l1b là gì ạ 40.000
thì tương tự trong cái ví dụ 2 thì mình
sẽ dùng cái hàm HD tại vì gì cái loại
phòng ở đây của mình được bố trí theo
hàng ngang thì mình phải dùng cái gì ạ
Cái halog cấp này các bạn sẽ bằng hai
nút cấp các bạn ấn Tab nhé Thì Thành
Phần đầu tiên là cái giá trị dò tìm đúng
không ạ chính là cái loại phòng ở đây
phẩy thành phần thứ hai là bảng giá trị
dò tìm thì các bạn Bôi đen toàn bộ cái
vùng dữ liệu của cái biểu giá phòng này
phẩy thành phần thứ ba là cái hàng trả
về thì riêng với hai nút cấp thì không
phải là cột nữa mà là cái hàng trả về
đúng không vì mình đang tìm kiếm theo
hàng mà Thì ở đây là đơn giá tuần đúng
không các bạn sẽ tính từ cái hàng đầu
tiên là hàng loại phòng là một này đơn
giá tuần là hàng thứ hai đúng không Đấy
phải 2 ở đây phẩy không các bạn đóng
ngoặc lại
enter đấy thì như vậy nó ra đơn giá tuần
đúng không Đơn giá này cũng vậy nhé Nó
chỉ khác là cái hàng trả về sẽ là hàng
số 3 thôi các bạn sẽ bằng này hát lúc
cấp các bạn ấn Tab nhé Thành Phần đầu
tiên là loại phòng ở đây này phẩy thành
phần thứ hai là bảng giá trị dò ở đây
phẩy cái hàng trả về hàng số 3 đấy phẩy
không các bạn sẽ đóng ngoặc lại các bạn
enter đấy thì như vậy nó rất như vậy nó
sẽ ra cái loại phòng là gì ạ 30.000 bây
giờ các bạn sẽ tích đúp vào đây nhé Bây
giờ giả sử cái bảng giá trị dò tìm mình
Bôi đen Cái hàng 11 và hàng 12 đúng
không ạ thì mình sẽ thay cái số 13 này
bằng số 12 thì nó sẽ trả về gì đây Các
bạn thấy chưa cái vùng mà mình cái bảng
giá trị giò đây Các bạn thấy nó lùi đỏ
lên đây này các bạn enter nhé Nó sẽ báo
lỗi này Đấy nó sẽ báo lỗi cái repsphant
tức là gì ạ tại vì cái vùng dữ liệu mà
các bạn tìm kiếm nó chỉ ở hai hàng thôi
mà gì ạ Cái hàng mà các bạn trả về lại
là hàng số 3 Tức là cái hàng trở về nó
làm ngoài cái vùng các bạn tìm kiếm ở
đây cho nên nó sẽ báo cái lỗi refer ở
đây để các bạn chú ý nhé nếu như bạn nào
bị cái lỗi reprant ý Thông thường thì
cái vùng dữ liệu của các bạn bôi là nó
không đủ đúng không ạ Đấy vùng dữ liệu
của mình mình phải bôi từ cái hàng 11
đến hàng 13 cơ nhưng mà nếu ở đây là 12
thì sẽ không đúng ạ đấy cho nên ở đây
phải là 13 Nhưng mà nếu các bạn đánh 16
thì có sao không Không sao cả nhá miễn
là nó phải lớn hơn cái hàng mà trả về
Tức là cái hàng trả về hàng số 3 đúng
không thì các bạn phải bôi đen từ cái
hàng 11 đến tối thiểu là 13 các bạn có
thể làm 14 15 16 Tùy các bạn nhé Tại Ví
dụ mình cho là 16 đi nhé đấy các bạn
enter đấy nó sẽ vẫn ra đấy nhưng là nếu
như mà ở đây là hàng 12 là sẽ không ra
đâu đấy các bạn lưu ý cho mình nhé tương
tự cái Vlog cấp cũng vậy nhé ví dụ mình
thích đút vào đây Đấy nếu như mà mình
cần tìm đơn giá ngày nhé mà mình tìm từ
Cái ô thì Omega đến đến C7 này chứ không
phải d7 ví dụ mình thay D bằng C Đấy tức
là mình sẽ tìm hai cái cột này thôi cột
bê và cột C thôi trong khi cái cột trả
về lại là cột D cơ thì nó sẽ báo lỗi rap
đấy các bạn enter đấy các bạn thấy chưa
nó sẽ báo cái lỗi phần Tức là ở đây gì ạ
Cái cột trả về với cái hàm Vlookup nhé
Thì cái vùng dữ liệu của bạn nó phải
rộng hơn cái cột các bạn cần tìm đấy tối
thiểu đây phải là D các bạn có thể thay
bằng E = F cũng được nhé đây ví dụ là E
cho các bạn xem này Đấy tức là nó phải
lớn hơn hoặc bằng cái cột d này Đấy thì
mình bôi đến cái cột E là ok
đấy là cái Lưu ý với cả cái hàm Vlookup
và hai lúc cấp nhé Ok Bây giờ mình sẽ
đóng lại như vậy mình đã xong cái phần
câu hỏi của bài tập hôm trước là bài số
7 nhé
Hôm nay mình vào cái bài số 8 là các cái
hàm quan trọng khác nhé đấy các bạn sẽ
tích đúp lên
Ok hôm nay mình sẽ hướng dẫn các bạn là
ba cái loại hàm đầu tiên là cái hàm
sumorax Tiếp theo là cái hàm gì ạ các
hàm về thời gian và cuối cùng là cái hàm
index và mét nhé đầu tiên mình sẽ làm
cái hàm sumorac trước cho các bạn này ở
đây giả sử mình có dữ liệu là 4 ngày của
tháng tư đúng không ạ Đây là các cái sản
phẩm Đây là số lượng và đây là đơn giá
bây giờ mình cần tính tổng tiền làm được
bao nhiêu đúng ạ thì tổng tiền ấy Thông
thường các bạn sẽ lấy số lượng nhân Đơn
giá này số lượng nhân đơn giá sau đó các
bạn sẽ cộng tổng lại đúng không ạ Đấy
nếu như mà bình thường các bạn hay làm
như sau nhé các bạn sẽ bằng này các bạn
lấy số lượng này nhân với cả gì ạ nhân
với đơn giá đây các bạn enter đấy Ở đây
các bạn có thể tích đúp nhá đấy các bạn
vẹt thẻ hôm này trong cái cửa sổ lumper
format đây các bạn sẽ chọn cái general
hoặc các bạn chọn number đều được nhé ví
dụ mình chọn general đi đấy các bạn sẽ
tích đúp vào đây
này đi thì như vậy Ở đây mình có tổng
giá của các cái mặt hàng này rồi đúng
không ạ Ở đây các bạn sẽ bằng xăm nhé
các bạn có thể bấm An bằng này Đấy phím
tắt là hàm Sum các bạn enter thì như vậy
tổng tiền của các sản phẩm bán được là
từng này tức là 38.278 này Bây giờ mình
sẽ không dùng cái cách này nhé mình sẽ
dùng một cái hàm rất đơn giản làm xong
các bác nhé đấy các bạn xóa đi
thì để tính tổng tiền của cái các cái
sản phẩm này thì mình sẽ dùng cái hàm
Sum rác nhá thì ở đây mình sẽ hướng dẫn
các bạn là cái hàm sumorax dùng cơ bản
này xong rác dùng nâng cao đây là nâng
cao hơn và đây là còn nâng cao hơn nữa
nhé thì đầu tiên là mình sẽ hướng dẫn
các bạn sử dụng cái hàm sumborac cơ bản
này thì cái hàm sumbrat thì các bạn sẽ
bằng này sang
Project nó được tô đậm đây này các bạn
sẽ ấn phím Tab đấy như vậy đây là cái cú
pháp của hàm Sum rác thì cái hàm sumorax
nó gồm các cái mảng đúng không ạ Đấy các
cái mảng Ơ đây một là mảng một này 2
bằng 3 lại cứ như vậy nha các bạn có thể
chọn bao nhiêu mảng cũng được thì ở đây
cái mảng một của mình các bạn có thể Bôi
đen là cái phần số lượng đúng không ạ
phẩy cái mảng hai là gì chính là cái
phần đơn giá ở đây đấy các bạn hiểu như
thế này Nếu như các bạn Bôi đen như thế
này thì nó sẽ lấy D4 nhân E4 này cộng
với cả D5 nhân E5 + D6 nhân S6 đấy Cứ
như vậy đến diện đến D15 nhân e15 và nó
sẽ cộng tổng lại nhé đấy các bạn sẽ đóng
ngoặc đơn lại để xong cái hàm Sum borax
này thì ở đây mình dùng mỗi hai mảng
thôi là mảng số lượng và mạng đơn giá
nhé đấy các bạn sẽ enter đấy các bạn
thấy chưa Đúng là 38.278 đấy bằng cái
cách mà lúc nãy mình hướng dẫn các bạn
đúng không ạ Đấy các bạn có thể ấn vào
đây để nó gì ạ nó tạo cái dấu phẩy ngăn
cách giữa hàng nghìn nhìn nó sẽ rõ hơn
đúng không ạ Ok Bây giờ các bạn sẽ tích
đúp vào đây nhé thì các bạn chú ý nhé
Lúc nãy mình Bôi đen là gì ạ Cái cột D
trước Tức là cái phần số lượng trước sau
đó đến phần đơn giá nhé nhưng mà cái
phần nào trước cũng không quan trọng đâu
các bạn có thể cho cái phần đơn giá
trước này các bạn Xóa đi này Đấy sau đó
bạn phải là
cái phần số lượng này thì cái phần nào
trước cũng được nhé Nó sẽ không ảnh
hưởng đến kết quả của mình nhá đấy các
bạn thấy không ạ Ok sang cái cách sử
dụng thứ hai là cái hàm sumorax nâng cao
nhé bây giờ Giả sử có hai cái câu hỏi
mình cần tính số lượng của gái xem một
và thành tiền của cái sản phẩm là gãi
cho một thôi thì mình làm như thế nào
thì đầu tiên là số lượng của gãy trong
một nhá đúng không ạ đây ví dụ các bạn
tích vào số lượng của gái theo một của
ngày mùng 1 này các bạn giữ cần troll
nhé Đây gái xem một đây này gái xem một
gái xem một đấy các bạn giữ cần troll
này các bạn Bôi đen bốn cái ô này các
bạn sẽ xuống dưới cái thanh status bar
này các bạn sẽ thấy chưa tổng của nó là
gì ạ 634 Thì bây giờ mình làm thế nào để
mình tính được cái số lượng của các cái
sản phẩm gái theo một mà mình đã bán
được nhá thì mình làm như thế nào để bây
giờ các bạn sẽ tích vào cái ô gì oh7 để
các bạn lập công thức này các bạn sẽ
bằng gì ạ
sau đó các bạn ấn Tab nhé Thì lúc này nó
đã có một cái mở ngoặc Sẵn đây rồi đúng
không các bạn sẽ ấn thêm một cái mở
ngoặc đơn nữa đấy Cái mở ngoặc đơn Thứ
hai này nó sẽ là cho cái phần mình đặt
điều kiện nhé thì các bạn sẽ Bôi đen Cái
vùng điều kiện ở đây là các cái sản phẩm
đúng không ạ Các bạn sẽ bằng gì ạ bằng
cái điều kiện là gái theo một ở đây đúng
không ạ Các bạn sẽ đóng ngoặc đơn lại để
xong cái phần điều kiện đúng ạ Đấy bây
giờ các bạn sẽ phẩy nhá cái phần Ơ đây 2
là gì ạ chính là cái phần số lượng ở đây
đấy các bạn chú ý nhé Nếu như mà các bạn
không có cái errary nào nữa thì nó sẽ
hiểu là cái phần số lượng ở đây nó sẽ
nhân với 1 đấy các bạn đóng ngoặc lại để
xong cái hàm sau thì như vậy cái hàm
sumat này nó sẽ làm gì nó sẽ Quét tất cả
các sản phẩm gái theo một ở đây Nếu như
mà bằng H6 ấy thì nó mới thực hiện cái
gì cái ô từ d4d D15 nhân với 1 đúng
không ạ Bây giờ các bạn enter nhé Nhưng
mà nếu các bạn enter theo cái cách này
thì nó sẽ bằng 0 này Đấy ví dụ mình cứ
enter đi đấy các bạn thấy chưa nó sẽ
bằng 0 ạ Tại vì sao bây giờ các bạn sẽ
tích đúp vào đây nhá thì các bạn chú ý
nhá cái biểu thức gì ạ Cái biểu thức
điều kiện này này là cái mở ngoặc đơn
của C4 đến C15 bằng H6 đóng ngoặc đơn
nhé thì nó sẽ trả về kết quả là Chu và
phôi nhá Đấy thì bây giờ để cái biểu
thức này nó trả về
11 hoặc không ấy thì bạn làm hai cách
nhé Cách thứ nhất là các bạn có thể diện
đấy các bạn có thể trước cái phần mở
ngoặc C4 C15 bằng H6 này các bạn sẽ cho
hai cái dấu trừ ở đây đấy thì nó sẽ
chuyển cái phần biểu thức này về thành
không hoặc một nha các bạn enter đấy thì
lúc này nó sẽ trả về là gì ạ 634 này Bây
giờ các bạn sẽ tích đúp vào Cái ô này
thì ngoài hai cái dấu trừ này các bạn có
thể dùng cách hai là gì ạ Các bạn có thể
nhân với 1 Tức là mình sẽ chuyển nó về
cái dạng số nhé để mình sẽ chuyển true
về dạng 0 hoặc 1 thì sau cái biểu thức
mà gì ạ C4 C15 bằng H6 đóng ngoặc đơn
này các bạn sẽ nhân với 1 đấy thì lúc
này nó sẽ trả về kết quả như mình mong
muốn đấy là 634 thì có hai cách nhé Thì
mình sẽ dùng cái cách nhân một này đi
đấy Tiếp theo là cái phần thành tiền nhá
thành tiền thì nó sẽ giống hệt cái phần
số lượng nhưng mà gì nó sẽ thêm một cái
mảng nữa là cái phần đơn giá ở đây đấy
thì mình sẽ bằng bằng sampled này các
bạn ấn mũi tên xuống Sau đó các bạn ấn
Tab nhé Sau đó các bạn lại thêm một cái
mở ngoặc đơn nữa để các bạn làm cái phần
điều kiện đúng các bạn để thì các bạn sẽ
Bôi đen cái phần sản phẩm ở đây để các
bạn sẽ bằng diện bằng cái sản phẩm gái
theo một này đấy các bạn sẽ đóng ngoặc
lại để các bạn xong cái phần điều kiện
nhé các bạn nhân với 1 để chuyển nó về
dạng số đúng ạ phẩy cái mảng thứ hai
chính là cái mảng số lượng ở đây đấy
phẩy mảng thứ 3 chính là cái mảng đơn
giá ở đây đấy các bạn sẽ đóng ngoặc đơn
lại để xong khách hàng xong thì như vậy
là gì ạ Nó sẽ nhân cái phần số lượng
nhân với đơn giá chỉ với cái điều kiện
là gì ạ điều kiện là các cái sản phẩm ở
đây bằng gái theo một thôi đấy các bạn
sẽ enter Các bạn thấy là đấy nó sẽ ra là
gì 11.978 thì bây giờ ví dụ cái gái xem
một là mình sửa thành cái CO2 nhé đấy
các bạn enter đấy các bạn thấy chưa cả
cái phần số lượng và cái phần thành tiền
nó đều thay đổi là bây giờ các bạn tích
đuốc vào đây các bạn sửa thành điện lái
xe 3 các bạn enter Đấy thấy chưa Nó sẽ
thay đổi cả về số lượng và thành tiền
mình sẽ chuyển về gái cho một đi
ok cách dùng tiếp theo của cái hàm Sum
rác là gì ạ Bây giờ mình muốn tính theo
cái điều kiện là gì ạ Bây giờ mình giống
như cái phần của cái Cách thứ Hai nhé
mình sẽ tính số lượng và thành tiền với
điều kiện là gì ạ gạch theo một cộng với
cả gái 63 tức là cứ gái theo một và gái
cho ba thì mình sẽ tính nhá đúng không ạ
Tức là mình sẽ không tính cái số 2 Đấy
thì các bạn sẽ bằng này các bạn sẽ bằng
sampled này các bạn ấn mũi tên xuống và
các bạn ấn Tab nhé sau đó là gì Các bạn
sẽ mở ngoặc đơn để các bạn tạo một cái
vùng điều kiện đúng ạ thì cái vùng điều
kiện thứ nhất này các bạn sẽ Bôi đen Cái
vùng điều kiện thứ nhất đấy các bạn sẽ
bằng gì ạ bằng cái gáy cho một này này
chính là cái Oh 11 nhé đấy các bạn sẽ
đóng ngoặc đơn này các bạn nhân với 1
Đấy mình sẽ chuyển nó về cái dạng số 0
và 1 nhé Sau đó các bạn cộng với gì ạ
Các bạn cộng với mở ngoặc để mình sẽ tạo
cái vùng điều kiện thứ hai đúng không
vẫn là cái điều kiện sản phẩm ở đây đấy
các bạn bằng diện bằng với gái số 3 đấy
các bạn sẽ đóng ngoặc đơn lại và các bạn
nhân với 1 đấy thì như vậy là mình đã
xong cái vùng điều kiện ở đây nhé là gì
ạ là xong cái điều kiện là bằng cái theo
một và gái cho Ba rồi đúng không ạ bây
giờ phẩy đến cái mảng ở đây Thứ hai này
này chính là cái phần số lượng ở đây
đấy các bạn sẽ đóng ngoặc đơn lại để các
bạn xong cái hàm sumod đã các bạn enter
đấy các bạn thấy chưa Như vậy là gì ạ
với gái sau một và gái CO3 là 1286 bây
giờ thành tiền cũng vậy nhé thành tiền
thì nó sẽ giống hệt ở đây và nó thêm cái
điều kiện đơn giá vào đây thôi Đấy mình
sẽ làm luôn nhé các bạn bằng xong Block
này các bạn ấn mũi tên xuống ấn Tab nhé
Sau đó các bạn mở ngoặc đơn nữa để các
bạn tạo cái điều kiện này đầu tiên mình
sẽ Bôi đen Cái vùng sản phẩm đây đúng
không ạ bằng với diện bằng cái C1 ở đây
đấy các bạn sẽ đóng ngoặc đơn lại các
bạn nhân với 1 để chuyển về dạng số đúng
không các bạn sẽ cộng với gì ạ cộng gì
cộng với mở ngoặc nhé các bạn lại Bôi
đen tiếp vẫn là cái sản phẩm này nhưng
mà ở đây mình sẽ bằng bằng thêm với cả
cái điều kiện gái cho ba ở đây đấy các
bạn sẽ đóng ngoặc lại và các bạn nhân
với 1 đấy thì như vậy mình đã xong ở đây
là hai cái điều kiện là kết hợp của gái
sau một cùng với cả cái điều kiện gái
cho ba đúng không ạ Các bạn phải này đến
cái nơi thứ hai chính là gì ạ chính là
cái số lượng ở đây
phẩy đến cái ở đây thứ ba chính là cái
đơn giá ở đây nhé đấy các bạn sẽ đóng
ngoặc đơn này để xong cái hàm sumorax
bây giờ mình sẽ enter đấy các bạn thấy
chưa Rất là hay ví dụ gái xem một và gái
CO2 nhé các bạn tích đúp vào đây các bạn
sửa này
các bạn enter đấy Bạn thấy chưa số lượng
và thành tiền đã thay đổi cuối cùng mình
sẽ hướng dẫn các bạn thêm gì ạ Ngoài cái
phần gái sau một và gái sau 3 mình sẽ
thêm các cái điều kiện ví dụ là mình sẽ
tính doanh thu của một cái ngày là ngày
mùng 3 tháng 4 thôi và gì ạ và Những Cái
Ô mà số lượng mà nó lớn hơn 130 Đấy tức
là ở đây sẽ rất là nhiều điều kiện là
gái theo một cộng với gái theo ba này
Điều kiện thứ hai là gì ạ ngày mùng 3
tháng 4 và điều kiện thứ ba là chỉ các
cái số lượng mà lớn hơn 130 thôi đúng
không đấy thì để làm việc này các bạn
làm như sau nhé các bạn sẽ bằng này xăm
product các bạn ấn mũi tên xuống các bạn
ấn Tab nhé để các bạn sẽ thêm một cái mở
ngoặc nữa là cái mở ngoặc thứ hai đúng
không các bạn lại thêm một cái mở ngoặc
đơn nữa là cái mở ngoặc thứ ba thì tại
sao lại nhiều cái ngoặc đơn này mình sẽ
giải thích nhé đầu tiên các đầu tiên các
bạn vẫn bôi là cái vùng sản phẩm ở đây
đấy các bạn bằng với gì ạ bằng cái gáy
theo một này các bạn đóng ngoặc lại để
xong cái điều kiện là gái cho một nhé
các bạn cộng gì ạ cộng với mở ngoặc đấy
các bạn lại Bôi đen cái phần sản phẩm ở
đây
các bạn bằng video
nữa Ok Bây giờ các bạn sẽ xuống cuối này
như vậy là mình đã xong cái phần điều
kiện là gái theo một cùng với gái sau 3
nhé các bạn phải đóng ngoặc đơn lại nữa
đấy thì như vậy Cái đó ngoặc đơn này nó
đã kết thúc cái việc gì ạ đây kết thúc
hai cái phần này rồi đúng không Đấy như
vậy mình đã xong cái điều kiện thứ nhất
ở trên này là gái theo một với cái sau 3
Đúng không các bạn phải nhân với cả mở
ngoặc đấy Ở đây nhé với nhiều điều kiện
mà không liên quan đến nhau nhé Tiếp
theo là cái điều kiện ngày tháng đúng
không thì các bạn sẽ nhân miếng mở ngoặc
để nhân với cái vùng điều kiện tiếp theo
thì điều kiện tiếp theo là gì Các bạn
Bôi đen cái phần ngày tháng ở đây này
Đấy Mà nó bằng gì bằng với cái ngày
tháng ở đây
đấy các bạn có thể đóng ngoặc đơn lại
Đấy mình đã xong cái ngày tháng nhé Bây
giờ các bạn nhân tiếp Tức là mình sẽ
nhân thêm cái điều kiện thứ ba Các bạn
mở ngoặc đơn ra điều kiện thứ ba là gì ạ
Cái phần số lượng ở đây phải gì ạ phải
lớn hơn cái mình đặt ở đây là 130 đúng
không ạ Các bạn sẽ đóng ngoặc đơn lại
như vậy Ở đây mình đã xong ba cái điều
kiện nhé bằng ba cái dấu đóng ngoặc đơn
này đấy thì như vậy sau ba cái điều kiện
này nha các bạn chú ý nhé Đây này kết
thúc cái điều kiện này nó còn cái mở
ngoặc đơn ngoài cùng cho cái hàm sumod
thôi đấy thì ở đây các bạn có thể nhân
với 1 nữa đấy thì ở đây như vậy hai cái
này các bạn có thể không cần nhân với 1
cũng được đấy hai cái này các bạn có thể
không cần nhân với 1 nhé vì cái biểu
thức Cuối Cùng Ở đây mình đã nhân với 1
Để mình chuyển về dạng số rồi nhé đấy
phẩy Tiếp theo là cái thứ hai lúc này
rất là dễ thôi thì các bạn sẽ Bôi đen
cái phần số lượng ở đây chính là cái ở
đây thứ Hai nhé các bạn sẽ đóng ngoặc
đơn lại để xong khách hàng samurage các
bạn enter đấy như vậy số lượng ở đây là
thành gì 333 bây giờ mình sẽ kiểm tra
cho các bạn nhé thì đầu tiên là gì ạ đầu
tiên mình cái điều kiện thứ nhất là ngày
mùng 3 nhé các bạn vào cái phần ngày này
các bạn
bỏ chặn hết đi các bạn và chọn ngày mùng
3 các bạn enter này Đấy tiếp theo là gì
ạ là cái gái sau một và gái sau 3 thôi
đúng không Mình sẽ bỏ cái gáy theo hai
đi đấy vì hai cái số lượng này đều là
luôn 130 đúng không Thì nó sẽ tính tổng
của hai cái ô này các bạn giữ cần troll
các bạn Bôi đen đã thấy chưa bằng đúng
333 luôn đấy bây giờ ví dụ cái điều kiện
là 150 nhé Nếu như các bạn Nhập 150 thì
cái kết quả nó sẽ trả về 184 đúng không
vì nó sẽ không tính cái trường hợp 149
mà 149 nó nhỏ hơn 150 các bạn enter này
đấy các bạn thấy chưa nó sẽ trả về 184
ngay đấy rất là hay bây giờ mình sẽ ấn
đu đấy như vậy là 333 nhé đấy các bạn sẽ
tích vào đây mình sẽ bỏ phim tươi hết đi
các bạn sẽ clear sản phẩm này các bạn
kích vào đây các bạn clear cái này đấy
như vậy Ở đây mình đã số lượng là 333
cách thành tiền cũng vậy nhé thành tiền
thì thêm cái thứ ba là cái phần đơn giá
Thôi thì ở đây mình sẽ làm luôn và mình
không giải thích nhé các bạn bằng xong
Bù Đăng này các bạn ấn mũi tên xuống và
các bạn ấn Tab đấy Sau đó các bạn sẽ bấm
thêm hai cái mở ngoặc đơn nữa đấy như
vậy tất cả là mình đã có ba cái mở ngoặc
đơn rồi đúng không các bạn sẽ Bôi đen
cái phần Sản phẩm này Đấy bằng gì ạ bằng
cái gáy theo một ở đây các bạn đóng
ngoặc đơn lại sau đó cộng gì cộng với mở
ngoặc các bạn tiếp tục bôi đen Cái sản
phẩm ở đây và bằng bằng cái gạch CO3 này
các bạn sẽ đóng ngoặc đơn lại để Xong
rồi Xong cái điều kiện là gái theo một
và gái sau 3 nhé các bạn đóng ngoặc đơn
nữa Để xong cái vùng điều kiện thứ nhất
bây giờ các bạn sẽ nhân gì nhân với mở
ngoặc Tiếp theo là cái vùng điều kiện
thứ hai chính là cái cột ngày tháng ở
đây bằng bằng cái ô ngày mùng 3 ở đây
nhé
các bạn sẽ đóng ngoặc đơn lại để xong
cái vùng điều kiện thứ hai các bạn nhân
với cả gì ạ mở ngoặc đơn ra vùng điều
kiện thứ ba là gì ạ Cái số lượng ở đây
này phải gì ạ phải lớn hơn
cái mình đặt ở đây là 130 Đúng không các
bạn sẽ đóng ngoặc đơn lại thì như vậy
mình đã xong ba cái điều kiện này rồi
nhé Bây giờ mình sẽ nhân với 1 để chuyển
về dạng 011 đúng không phẩy tiếp theo
các bạn sẽ Bôi đen cái phần số lượng này
Đấy phẩy cái ở thứ ba chính là cái phần
đơn giá ở đây đấy các bạn sẽ đóng ngoặc
lại để xong cái hàm Sum bù đắp nhé các
bạn enter đấy như vậy thành tiền đấy là
gì ạ thành tiền là
4732 các bạn thấy rất là hay Ví dụ mình
sẽ thay cái mùng 3 này các bạn tích đúp
nhá mình sẽ sửa ngày mùng 3 bằng điện
bằng ngày mùng 1 đi các bạn enter đấy
các bạn thấy chưa số lượng và thành tiền
đã thay đổi rất là hay ví dụ cái điều
kiện ở đây là quy định là diện lớn hơn
150 đi
thì 150 hoặc là 180 đi Mình xem nào đấy
thì như vậy không có sản phẩm là lớn 180
đúng không nó sẽ bằng không hết đấy mình
sẽ
quy định là 130 thôi
Ok như vậy là mình đã xong cho các bạn
cái hàm sumorax Này nhé cái hàm sumax
này dùng cũng khá là hay đấy ạ tiếp theo
mình sẽ giới thiệu các bạn các cái hàm
về thời gian nhé các bạn sẽ tích vào cái
sheet function ở đây này Đấy thì ở đây
mình có các cái mốc thời gian là như thế
này nhé Đấy Bây giờ mình sẽ cần tính
ngày thì ở đây là gì ạ Ở đây mình có là
gì Các trường Thời Gian rồi bây giờ mình
sẽ lấy ngày bằng gì Các bạn sẽ dùng cái
hàm đây thôi rất là đơn giản và nằm đây
các bạn sẽ mở ngoặc thì thành phần của
cái hàm đây này là cái ô chứa thời gian
nhé các bạn sẽ tích vào đây đấy Ở đây là
ngày 28 tháng 10 như các bạn biết ý thì
trong Excel thông thường mặc định nó sẽ
viết tháng trước sau đến ngày đến 5 đúng
không Thì ở đây cái hàm này nó sẽ trả về
ngày 28 này đấy các bạn enter đấy nó sẽ
trở về 28 Đúng không các bạn sẽ tích đúp
vào đây đấy thì như vậy mình đã có các
cái ngày của các cái mốc thời gian ở đây
rồi nhé tiếp theo là tính thứ nhé Thì
nếu như mà tính thứ bằng tiếng Anh thì
nó sẽ đơn giản hơn các bạn sẽ dùng cái
hàm text này các bạn sẽ bằng text đấy
các bạn sẽ ấn Tab nhé Thì hôm trước
trong bài về các hàm xử lý chuỗi mình đã
giới thiệu về hàm text rồi đúng không
Thì đầu tiên là cái value thì chính là
gì ạ chính là cái thời gian ở đây đấy
mình sẽ đổi về vali gì Các bạn phải lên
mình sẽ pho mát của cái thời gian này
các bạn sẽ mở ngoặc kép ra các bạn
format về dạng này đúng không các bạn sẽ
đánh cho mình là gì ạ Ba cái chữ d đấy
đánh ba chữ d và các bạn sẽ đóng ngoặc
kép lại các bạn sẽ đóng ngoặc đơn lại
các bạn enter nó sẽ trả về thứ tiếng Anh
là USD nhé các bạn sẽ tích đúp vào đây
đấy chứ Đây sang đây file đây là chủ
nhật này Thứ Sáu đây các bạn sẽ tích nút
vào đây nhé Nếu như mà các bạn cho bốn
cái chữ D 4 chữ d thì nó sẽ trả về cái
ngày đầy đủ Còn 3 chữ d thì nó sẽ là
ngày Viết tắt đây Các bạn thấy chưa nó
sẽ là ngày đầy đủ Đây là cái cách mà
mình trả về thứ của tiếng Anh còn nếu
như mà trả về thứ tiếng Việt thì mình
làm như thế nào đây mình sẽ Bôi đen mình
xóa đi thì các bạn sẽ bằng nhé Nếu mà
thứ tiếng Việt các bạn mở ngoặc kép ra
các bạn sẽ gõ cái chữ là thứ này các bạn
cách ra các bạn đóng ngoặc kép lại sau
đó các bạn và Tức là mình sẽ nối chuỗi
nhá và cái hàm weekday hàm weekday nó sẽ
trả về thứ đấy đấy Good đây của gì của
cái ô thời gian ở đây thì cái WeChat của
cái ô thời gian nó sẽ trả về cái thứ
tương ứng các bạn sẽ đóng ngoặc lại các
bạn enter đấy nó sẽ trả về thứ Tư nhé
đấy các bạn tích đúp vào đây thì các bạn
chú ý cho mình nhé cái hàm weekday mặc
định của nó nếu nếu như bằng 1 thì nó sẽ
trả về chủ nhật đúng không còn các cái
thứ còn lại là từ 2 đến 7 thì nó sẽ
tương ứng với đây trả về là 2 đến 7 đấy
thì riêng cái điều kiện chủ nhật ở đây
thì các bạn chú ý cho mình thôi thì với
trường hợp này mình sẽ dùng cái hàm If
nhá Đây mình sẽ xóa đi thì như vậy mình
sẽ dùng cái hàm if if này bằng này ý các
bạn ấn Tab nhé Nếu như mà gì ạ
của cái ô thời gian ở đây các bạn đóng
ngoặc lại và bằng gì bằng 1 đấy thì các
bạn phải các bạn sẽ trả về kết quả là gì
ạ Các bạn sẽ ghi là chủ nhật nhé CN cũng
được hoặc các bạn Gõ cái chữ chủ nhật đi
đấy các bạn đóng ngoặc kép lại phẩy còn
ngược lại thì các bạn làm như vừa xong
thôi các bạn mở ngoặc kép ra các bạn sẽ
ghi cái chữ là gì thứ cách đóng ngoặc
kép lại các bạn vào với cái hàm weekday
các bạn ấn mũi tên xuống ấn Tab USD của
cái ô thời gian này các bạn đóng ngoặc
đơn này để sang hàng weekday các bạn
đóng ngoặc đơn lại để xong hàm If đấy
các bạn enter đây là Thứ Tư đúng không
các bạn tích đúp vào đây đấy thì riêng
cái chủ nhật này thì nó là weekday bằng
là một rồi đúng không ạ Đấy rất là hay ở
đây nếu như mà mình quay lại tiếng Anh
đi nhé mình sẽ xóa đi Mình thích dùng
tiếng Anh thì các bạn rất đơn giản các
bạn bằng cái hàm text Thôi ấn Tab này
đầu tiên là cái ô thời gian phẩy các bạn
mở ngoặc kép ra mình sẽ viết tắt của thứ
thôi mình sẽ viết tắt 3 cái chữ rd thì
nó sẽ trả về cái thứ viết tắt nhá các
bạn đóng vào đơn lại enter đấy nó sẽ ra
là web đây các bạn tích đúp vào đây
tiếp theo là tính tháng nhé tháng thì nó
cũng giống như là thứ thôi các bạn sẽ
bằng các bạn dùng cái hàm ăn để các bạn
sẽ ấn Tab nhé thì các bạn sẽ chọn vào
cái ô thời gian mà các bạn cần lấy tháng
đúng không các bạn sẽ đóng ngoặc đơn lại
enter đấy Ở đây nó là tháng 10 các bạn
thích đút vào đây đấy Còn nếu như các
bạn thêm cái chữ tháng nhé bạn thích đút
vào đây nhé Nếu như các bạn thêm cái
tháng thì các bạn sẽ bằng này các bạn mở
ngoặc kép ra các bạn gõ thêm cái chữ
tháng ở đây cho nó tường minh cho các
bạn cách ra các bạn đóng ngoặc kép lại
các bạn vào mấy cái hàm ăn này nó sẽ ra
tháng 10 đúng không
Còn nếu như mà muốn tháng bằng tiếng Anh
thì các bạn lại dùng
11 tháng 9 là bao nhiêu đấy thì mình sẽ
dùng cái hàm gì Các bạn sẽ dùng cái hàm
norman nhé các bạn bằng này thì các bạn
chú ý nhé trong cái bài này thì các cái
hàm mà mình sử dụng mình đã để mở trên
này để các bạn dễ nhớ nhá đấy các bạn sẽ
ghi là gì e o đấy các bạn ấn Tab thì đầu
tiên là cái status chính là cái ngày ở
đây đúng không ạ phẩy cái mắt ở đây thì
chính là cái số tháng mà mình cộng thêm
đúng không Thì ở đây mình không cộng
thêm cái tháng nào cả mà mình muốn biết
cái ngày cuối cùng của cái tháng này
thôi thì các bạn sẽ gì ạ Các bạn sẽ đánh
số 0 vào đây các bạn đóng ngoặc lại các
bạn enter đấy thì ở đây nó đang là định
dạng số đúng không các bạn tích vào đây
các bạn lên cái phần general này các bạn
sẽ chọn là gì ạ Các bạn sẽ chọn cái nòng
điếc hoặc soát đi Ví dụ mình chọn là gì
ạ Soft đi đấy các bạn thấy chưa nó sẽ ra
là 31 tháng 10 ở đây các bạn tích đúp
vào đây Đấy nếu như mà gì ạ Bây giờ các
bạn sẽ tích đút vào công thức này Nếu
như các bạn tăng thêm 1 tháng ấy đấy thì
nó sẽ lấy cái ngày cuối cùng của cái
tháng 11 ở đây này Đấy Đây là đang là
tháng 10 nhá các bạn thêm số 1 ở đây tức
là nó sẽ tăng thêm một tháng nay các bạn
enter đấy thì
phía sau là ngày mùng 1 tháng 11
đấy thì như vậy Ở đây á ví dụ ở đây nhá
Đây là ngày mùng 7 tháng 4 đúng không
Mình sẽ sửa thành tháng 12 đấy các bạn
enter đấy thì như vậy gì ạ Cái ngày đầu
tiên của tháng sau nó sẽ ra là ngày mùng
1 tháng 1 của năm 2021 rất là hay
tiếp theo là gì mình muốn tính cái ngày
này 5 năm sau thì mình làm như thế nào
đấy thì các bạn rất đơn giản thôi nhé
các bạn sẽ bằng gì ạ bằng cái edit này
các bạn ấn Tab nhé Thì cái status là gì
chính là cái ngày này đúng không ạ Đấy
phẩy mình sẽ lấy số tháng thêm là gì ở
đây là 5 năm đúng không Thì mình sẽ lấy
12 ở đây là 5 năm đúng không Mình sẽ
nhân với 5 các bạn sẽ đóng ngoặc đơn lại
để sang hàm edit các bạn enter đấy thì ở
đây nó đang là định dạng số đúng không
các bạn vẫn vào thẻ home nhé trong cái
phần gì trong cái ô number format này
các bạn sẽ chọn sót date ở đây đấy thì
như vậy là 5 năm sau nó sẽ ra là ngày 28
tháng 10 năm 2025 đấy nó sẽ tăng lên là
5 năm các bạn tích đúp vào đây đấy Bạn
thấy chưa Toàn bộ nó sẽ ra vào năm 2025
và ngày tháng là nó sẽ giống hệt ở bên
này Đấy
là cách mà mình sử dụng edit nhé Ví dụ ở
đây không phải là 5 năm mà là 10 tháng
thì sao ạ thì các bạn sẽ tích vào đây
các bạn sẽ gì Các bạn sẽ không phải là
12 nhân 5 nữa mà các bạn sẽ tích số 10
đây tức là 10 tháng thôi Đấy Bây giờ
mình sẽ bấm Escape nhé
tiếp theo là gì ạ Mình sẽ tính Ví dụ ở
đây mình yêu cầu là tính 15 ngày làm
việc tiếp theo tính từ cái mốc thời gian
này thì mình làm như thế nào đấy các bạn
có thể bằng nhé các bạn dùng cái hàm
work đây
các bạn sẽ ấn mũi tên xuống này Quốc đây
chấm thì in ntn đây các bạn ấn tag nhé
đấy thì đầu tiên cái status là gì ạ
chính là cái ngành này Đấy phẩy tiếp
theo là số ngày mà các bạn cần tăng thêm
đúng không số này cần tăng thêm là đây
là mình yêu cầu là tăng thêm 10 năm ngày
đúng không phẩy cái tùy chọn tiếp theo
là gì ạ là cái Quick can tức là nghỉ vào
ngày nào đúng không Các bạn thấy chưa ở
đây nó có tất cả là gì 17 cái tùy chọn
thì mặc định cái số 1 là gì ạ là cái thứ
7 và chủ nhật là ngày cuối tuần thì nếu
như mà Thứ Bảy Chủ nhật mà ngày cuối
tuần ấy thì các bạn sẽ tích vào số 1
nhưng có một những công ty thì nó lại là
gì ạ chủ nhật và thứ hai đấy có những
công ty là thứ hai thứ ba thì tùy các
bạn nhé Có những cái công ty thì nó lại
chỉ nghỉ một ngày thôi Ví dụ ở đây là
sunday Tức là chỉ nghỉ cái ngày chủ nhật
thôi chỉ nghỉ ngày thứ hai đấy Cứ như
vậy nhé ví dụ mình chọn ở đây là gì ạ
thông thường là sẽ nghỉ thứ bảy chủ nhật
thì các bạn sẽ tích vào số 1 ở đây các
bạn tích đúp vào đây Đấy thì nó sẽ là ra
là tùy chọn thứ bảy chủ nhật là ngày
cuối tuần phải cái tùy chọn tiếp theo là
gì Là cái Holiday Tức là cái Holiday là
ngày nghỉ đúng không nó sẽ trừ đi cho
các bạn cả ngày nghỉ nữa thì ví dụ các
cái ngày nghỉ mình sẽ liệt kê ở cái vùng
dữ liệu ở đây đấy ví dụ ngày tết dương
lịch này ngày mùng 2 tháng 9 thì các bạn
sẽ Bôi đen toàn bộ cái vùng này nghỉ ở
đây các bạn sẽ đóng ngoặc đơn lại các
bạn enter thì ở đây Các bạn chú ý nhé Nó
sẽ ra gì ạ Nó sẽ ra cái dạng số về mình
sẽ chuyển về cái dạng date này đấy thì
cái 15 ngày làm việc tính từ ngày 28
tháng 10 nó sẽ đến tất cả là nó sẽ đến
tới cái ngày là 18 tháng 11 tích đúp vào
đây tiếp theo là gì ạ Mình sẽ tính cái
thứ hai gần nhất nhé
các bạn hiểu tức là ví dụ ở đây đây
không phải là thứ hai đúng không Đây là
When đây When đây là Thứ Tư đúng không
các bạn sẽ tích vào đây
là thứ tư thì cái ngày thứ hai gần nhất
thì các bạn phải lùi lại 2 ngày đấy các
bạn phải hiểu là như vậy nhé Thì bây giờ
mình sẽ tính thứ hai gần nhất của cái
mốc thời gian ở đây các bạn sẽ bằng gì
Các bạn sẽ lấy cái ô thời gian ở đây này
các bạn trừ đi gì ạ Trừ đi cái hàm
weekday
của cái thời gian ở đây này phẩy cái
kiểu trả về nha các bạn sẽ chọn cái số 3
này tức là gì ạ Monday thì là không đúng
không Đấy thứ hai thì mình sẽ chuyển về
không Và cuối cùng Chủ Nhật thì sẽ là 6
đấy các bạn sẽ chọn cái tùy chọn thứ ba
này các bạn sẽ đóng ngoặc đơn lại các
bạn enter thì nó sẽ ra là ngày 26 tháng
10 bây giờ mình sẽ kiểm tra nhé đây các
bạn sẽ tích vào đây này đây ví dụ đang
là tháng 10 rồi đúng không đấy các bạn
thấy chưa Này 26 tháng 10 là thứ hai này
các bạn thấy chưa đấy Cái ngày mình nhập
vào đây là 28 tháng 10 thì nó hỏi là cái
thứ hai gần nhất thì chính là cái ngày
26 ở đây đấy ví dụ là ngày 24 tháng 09
nhá các bạn sẽ là 24 tháng 9 này đây 24
tháng 9 là vào cái là vào cái thứ năm
này thì cái thứ hai gần nhất nó sẽ vào
ngày 21 tháng 9 này đây Các bạn thấy
chưa Bây giờ mình sẽ tích đuốc vào đây
kiểm tra này đấy các bạn thấy chưa nó sẽ
ra là 21 tháng 9 rất là hay
tiếp theo mình sẽ sang cái ví dụ thứ hai
thì trong ví dụ thứ hai mình có cái ngày
bắt đầu làm việc và cái ngày kết thúc
làm việc thì các bạn chú ý nha ở đây
mình lại thiếu cái phần này kết thúc rồi
Ví dụ mình nhập cái hàm Today đi các bạn
sẽ bằng cái Today các bạn ấn tag nhé các
bạn sẽ đóng ngoặc đơn lại thì các bạn
chú ý Mình sẽ gửi cái file lại cho các
bạn thì trong cái phần này kết thúc mình
sẽ cập nhật Cái ngày cụ thể thì ở đây
mình sẽ làm mẫu là ví dụ là ngành kết
thúc là ngày hôm nay đi Thì cái ngày hôm
nay mình đang ghi cái video này là ngày
26 tháng 10 Đúng không các bạn nháy
chuột phải mình sẽ copy
kéo dài Các bạn chọn Pasteur mình sẽ
chuyển nó về value nhé các bạn bấm ok
thì như vậy Ở đây đây đã ra cái ngày 26
tháng 10 rồi nhé Thì bây giờ mình cần
tính cái tổng số ngày làm việc của cái
bạn này đúng không đấy thì bạn sẽ bằng
các bạn sẽ lấy cái ngày kết thúc này các
bạn trừ đi gì ạ Trừ đi ngày bắt đầu thôi
đấy còn enter thì như vậy là tổng thời
gian làm việc của bạn này là gì 729 ngày
bạn tích đúp vào đây đấy thì ở đây lại
ra âm đúng không Bởi Ví dụ mình sẽ làm
gì ngày 27 tháng đây ví dụ là năm 2010
thôi nhé các bạn enter đấy làm 3.000
ngày cơ đấy thì như vậy mình đã có tổng
số ngày làm việc rồi nhé tiếp theo là gì
ạ Mình sẽ xuống ngay làm việc thì các
bạn chú nhé Cái tổng số ngày khác với số
ngày làm việc tổng số ngày là gì ạ Mình
tính cả cái ngày nghỉ và ngày cuối tuần
đúng không đấy Ở đây mình sẽ dùng cái
hàm đây giống như trên mình sẽ dùng cái
hàm netword đây này các bạn sẽ bằng này
các bạn ấn mũi tên xuống và các bạn ấn
Tab nhé thì kết hợp Network đây là gì
cái status là đây là ngày bắt đầu phẩy
em biết là ngày kết thúc phẩy cái
Holiday thì ví dụ ở đây toàn bộ là ngày
Holiday của mình đúng không nó sẽ trừ đi
Cái ngày hôm nay các bạn đóng ngoặc lại
thì các bạn chú ý nhé cái hàm nét box
đây thì nó mặc định là thứ bảy chủ nhật
là ngày nghỉ nhé các bạn enter đấy thì
như vậy Ở đây là gì ạ Xuống này làm việc
của bạn này là 513 ngày thôi rất là
nhiều ngày nghỉ đúng không các bạn thích
đút vào đây Đấy tiếp theo là gì mình sẽ
tính cái số 5 cộng với số tháng làm việc
đúng không các bạn sẽ bằng này các bạn
sẽ dùng cái hàm date cho mình nhé các
bạn chú ý nhé cái hàm DX thì nó sẽ không
có gợi nhắc đâu thì các bạn sẽ gõ đúng
cái chữ date vào đây này thêm chữ d nữa
sau đó các bạn gõ ít các bạn sẽ mở ngoặc
đơn ra đấy cái thành phần của cái hàm
Dead này là gì ạ Các bạn sẽ tích vào cái
ngày bắt đầu là b14 ở đây phẩy cái ngày
kết thúc ở đây đấy các bạn phẩy này các
bạn trả về số 5 Đúng không các bạn sẽ mở
ngoặc kép các bạn sẽ gõ chữ y là sẽ trả
về số 5 các bạn đóng ngoặc kép lại các
bạn đóng ngoặc đơn lại thì như vậy cái
hàm date này nó sẽ trả về số 5 bây giờ
các bạn cứ enter đi đấy thì nó sẽ trả về
là một năm đúng không Từ ngày 28 tháng
10 và đến ngày 26 tháng 10 Ví dụ ở đây
mà không phải là 28 mà là gì 26 hoặc 25
đi 26 đi Các bạn thấy chưa thì lúc này
nó sẽ trả về số 2 Đấy mình sẽ ấn lưu lại
thì như vậy Ở đây nó mới chỉ là hơn 1
năm và chưa đến đủ 2 năm thì các bạn
phải thêm cái số tháng nữa đúng không
các bạn tích đúp vào đây đấy các bạn
cộng vẫn là cộng với date
này các bạn mở ngoặc thì đầu tiên là cái
ngày bắt đầu này phẩy đến cái ngày kết
thúc này Đấy phẩy cái tùy chọn thứ ba là
gì Các bạn mở ngoặc kép ra các bạn ghi
chữ ym đấy nó sẽ lấy cái số tháng còn
lại sau khi trừ số 5 Đúng không các bạn
sẽ đóng ngoặc kép lại đóng ngoặc đơn lại
đấy Cái im đây này chính là nó sẽ lấy số
tháng mà dư ra để các bạn enter ở đây ở
đây không phải là cộng nha các bạn tích
đúp vào đây mình đây đang làm lối chuỗi
đúng không các bạn và này và đây là số
tháng đúng không Thì ở đây mình tất cả
là gì ạ và các bạn mở ngoặc ra là các
bạn thêm cái chữ 5 vào đây nhé cách ra
mình sẽ ghi chữ 5 các bạn đóng ngoặc kép
lại các bạn cách ra các bạn vào với cả
gì và với Deep ở đây cuối cùng chọn vào
cái gì Và với cả mở ngoặc kép các bạn
thêm cái chữ tháng vào đây đấy các bạn
đóng ngoặc kép lại có enter đấy các bạn
thấy chưa Như vậy bạn này là làm gì ạ 1
năm và 11 tháng gọi tích đúp vào đây đấy
các bạn thấy chưa Như vậy bạn này là gì
0 5 1 tháng Đây là tháng 9 và đây là
tháng 10 mà lại khá là hay ạ
Tiếp theo là cái ví dụ thứ ba nhé Thì ở
đây mình có ngày sinh bây giờ mình tính
số tuổi đúng không thì các bạn sẽ dùng
cái hàm dateep này này các bạn sẽ bằng
này
đấy
thì có cái ngày sinh ở đây phẩy cái ngày
kết thúc thì các bạn sẽ dùng cái hàm
Today đúng không to đây là trả về cái
ngày hôm nay thì các bạn chú ý nha cái
hàm Today nó phụ thuộc vào cái ngày mà
các bạn thực hành lấy ví dụ hôm nay mình
thực hành là ngày 26 tháng 10 năm 2020
thì nếu như các bạn thực hành vào năm
2021 chẳng hạn thì nó sẽ tính là của năm
2021 đấy thì nó phụ thuộc vào cái ngày
thực hành cho nên là cái kết quả của các
bạn có thể nó khác với kết quả của mình
đấy nhé đấy các bạn phẩy nhá các bạn sẽ
thêm cái tùy chọn là gì ạ Các bạn mở
ngoặc kép ra các bạn các bạn đóng ngoặc
kép lại các bạn đóng ngoặc đơn lại đấy
thì như vậy bạn này là số tuổi là 26
tuổi đúng không Từ năm 94 đến 5 gì đến
năm nay là 2020 thì đúng là 26 tuổi ở
đây là tháng 7 trong khi mình là tháng
10 thì đúng quá 26 tuổi luôn 26 tuổi 3
tháng đấy các bạn thích đút vào đây Đấy
thì mình sẽ tính được số tuổi đúng không
Bây giờ để tính số tháng nhé thì các bạn
bằng này đến ít
các bạn sẽ mở ngoặc đơn ra các bạn tích
vào cái ngày sinh phẩy Today thì nó
giống hệt với cả số tuổi thôi các bạn ấn
Tab này các bạn đóng ngoặc đơn lại để
xong cái hàm Today phẩy nó khác với cái
phần số tuổi là ở cái phần tùy chọn thôi
các bạn mở ngoặc kép ra nếu như mà các
bạn gõ chữ i m thì nó sẽ tính cái số
tháng dư còn lại đúng không Lúc đấy là
mình im bây giờ các bạn sẽ xóa đi các
bạn sẽ thay bằng cái m thôi là số tháng
thôi Đấy mà thường hay là mở hoa đều
được nhé các bạn đóng ngoặc kép lại đóng
ngoặc đơn lại đấy thì như vậy tất cả là
315 tháng đấy
Bây giờ các bạn tích đúp vào đây ví dụ
mình đổi cái m thường hình mở hoa nhé
Thì Kết quả nó như vậy nó không khác gì
cả nhé
cái số này cũng tương tự như vậy mình sẽ
dùng cái hàm date và mình sẽ thay cái
tùy chọn là thay cái m bằng cái chữ đ
thôi nhé là ngày đấy các bạn sẽ bằng
đấy các bạn mở ngoặc đơn ra status là
đây phải andreak là cái hàm Today các
bạn ấn Tab nhé các bạn đóng ngoặc đơn
này để xong hàm Today phẩy cái tùy chọn
là gì ạ Các bạn mở ngoặc kép ra các bạn
gõ chữ đ này đóng ngoặc kép lại đóng
ngoặc đơn lại đấy như vậy là bạn này là
9611 ngày đấy
thì như vậy mình đã giới thiệu Xong cho
các bạn một số hàm về hàm thời gian nhé
qua các ví dụ cụ thể luôn để các bạn
hiểu và các bạn áp dụng vào công việc
của mình nhé Cuối cùng mình sẽ giới
thiệu với các bạn về cái hàm index và
Mass cái hàm index of khá là hay đấy ạ
Đấy cái hàm index vào mét nó sẽ khắc
phục được cái nhược điểm của cái hàm
Vlookup thì tại sao nó lại khắc phục
nhược điểm được ở đây mình sẽ làm cho
các bạn dễ hiểu nhé Thì ở đây giả sử
Mình có họ tên bây giờ mình cần tìm điện
thoại đúng không thì mình sẽ dùng cái
hàm Vlookup này các bạn sẽ bằng Vlog cấp
các bạn ấn Tab nhé thì thành phần đầu
tiên của Vlog cấp chính là tên bạn
Nguyễn Văn Ba này đúng không ạ phẩy
thành phần thứ hai là bảng giá trị dò vì
ở đây mình đang cần tìm họ tên đúng
không Thì cái bảng giá trị giờ thì những
ở cái bài 7 hôm trước mình đã nói rồi
thì các bạn phải bôi đen từ cái phần họ
tên các bạn không được Bôi đen từ cái
phần thành phố nhé đấy bởi vì mình đang
tìm là tìm cái phần họ tên đâm ra cái
cột đầu tiên của cái vùng dữ liệu mà các
bạn chọn ấy Trong cái phần bảng giá trị
dò tìm thì nó phải chứa cái cột họ tên ở
đây cho nên cái vùng mà các bạn tìm kiếm
ở đây nó phải từ cái phần họ tên ở đây
này Đấy phẩy thành phần thứ ba là cột
trả về đúng không Mình sẽ tính từ cái
cột họ tên này 1 2 như vậy điện thoại ở
cột số 2 các bạn phải không Mình tìm
chính xác các bạn sẽ đóng ngoặc lại
enter đấy thì nó sẽ ra được điện thoại
bây giờ ví dụ mình cần tìm thành phố nhé
thì các bạn sẽ gõ thành phố ở đây Các
bạn chú ý mình sẽ gõ đúng cái thành phố
ở đây này các bạn enter Nếu như các bạn
tìm thành phố các bạn sẽ không dùng được
Vlog Cup tại vì với thành phố nó lại nằm
ở bên trái cái họ tên đấy Thì như ở bài
trước mình đã giải thích rồi Các bạn
muốn tìm cái dữ liệu gì thì nó phải nằm
ở bên phải của cái giá trị dò tìm Nếu
như mình đang tìm theo họ tên thì các
cái thành phần Mình cần tìm kiếm nó phải
làm ở bên phải họ tên nhưng mà nếu như
mà ở cái thành phố mình cần tìm kiếm Nó
lại nằm ở bên trái họ tên thì mình sẽ
không dùng được cái hàm Vlookup cho nên
mình phải dùng cái hàm index of
nó sẽ ưu việt hơn cái hàm Vlookup thì
ngoài tìm kiếm ở bên phải thì nó cũng
tìm kiếm được bên trái cho các bạn đấy
thì hôm nay mình sẽ giới thiệu cho các
bạn cách dùng Index bằng mét nhé Thì cái
hàm index đây cú pháp của nó đây và mess
cú pháp của nó ở đây đấy thì cái hàm
index nó sẽ có ba cái thành phần urray
và cái râu và cái color tức là Ơ đây là
cái vùng các bạn chọn và các bạn chọn ở
cái hàng nào Cột nào còn cái mép thì cục
là gì Cái mét thì nó sẽ có kiểu giá trị
Tìm kiếm vùng Tìm kiếm và kiểu trả về nó
cũng khá là giống với virus khớp đấy thì
ở đây mình sẽ làm luôn cho các bạn dễ
hiểu nhé đầu tiên mình sẽ hoàn cảnh cái
hàm index này thì ví dụ mà mình cần tìm
Thành phố của bạn Nguyễn Văn Ba đúng
không Mình sẽ bằng này Index này các bạn
ấn Tab nhé Thì nếu như mà cần tìm cái
phần thành phố thì đầu tiên các bạn sẽ
Bôi đen toàn bộ cái vùng dữ liệu đúng
không đấy mình chưa biết cần tìm cái gì
cả Mình cứ Bôi đen toàn bộ cái vùng dữ
liệu ở đây phẩy Tiếp theo là cái râu Tức
là ở cái hàng thứ mấy trong cái vùng dữ
liệu này thì bây giờ mình sẽ kiểm tra
bạn Nguyễn Văn Ban ở hàng thứ mấy Nguyễn
Văn Ba là hàng thứ hai đúng không hàng
thứ nhất là cái hàng tiêu đề hàng thứ
hai là cái hàng mà chứa các bạn Nguyễn
Văn Ban này đấy thì các bạn phải hai ở
đây đấy phẩy Tiếp theo là cái cột mà các
bạn trả về đúng không vì ở đây mình Bôi
đen Cái vùng dữ liệu từ thành phố đúng
không Thì cái cột trả về sẽ là cột số 1
luôn đấy là cột thành phố các bạn đóng
ngoặc đơn lại các bạn enter Các bạn thấy
chưa Nguyễn Văn Ban ở Hà Nội luôn đấy
Đây là cách mà mình dùng Index nhé Nhưng
mà nếu như mình thay Nguyễn Văn Ban này
thì cái hàm index này nó lại không tự
tay tại vì cái 2 với 1 ở đây mình đã cố
định đúng không cho nên mình phải thay
đổi hai một phụ thuộc vào tên ở đây đây
ví dụ nếu như mà không phải Nguyễn Văn
Ban mà là Nguyễn Duy Dương chẳng hạn thế
nhá đấy các bạn Bôi đen Nguyễn Duy Dương
này các bạn nháy chuột phải copy các bạn
tích vào đây Các bạn nhớ chuột phải các
bạn page nhá Đấy thì các bạn thấy chưa
cái thành phố nó vẫn là Hà Nội trong khi
bạn Nguyễn Duy Dương Thực ra phải là Hồ
Chí Minh Bây giờ các bạn tích đuốc vào
đây thì các bạn Nguyễn Duy Dương ấy thì
cái hàng trả về nó lại phải là hàng số 3
cơ đấy Nguyễn Duy Dương đang ở hàng số 3
tính từ cái phần tiêu đề họ tên ở đây
này đấy các bạn enter thì như vậy Ở đây
mình phải thay cái số 3 này bằng một cái
hàm nó có thể thay đổi theo họ tên được
đúng không Đấy tức là mình sẽ dùng cái
hàm mét Nó sẽ thay đổi được thì ngoài ra
Ví dụ không phải là thành phố Nha mà
mình cần tìm điện thoại bây giờ các bạn
nhớ chuột phải các bạn copy cả cái điện
thoại mình sẽ cop sang đây nhé mình sẽ
làm các bạn tích vào đây các bạn ctrl V
nhé Thì mình sẽ làm cái phần điện thoại
ở đây Nếu như mà điện thoại các bạn sẽ
phải bằng Index này các bạn ấn Tab nhé
đầu tiên các bạn Bôi đen toàn bộ cái
vùng dữ liệu đúng không Đấy phẩy cái
hàng trả về của bạn Nguyễn Duy Dương này
là hàng thứ ba đúng đúng không điện
thoại ở cái cột thứ mấy trong cái vùng
dữ liệu này thì điện thoại là cột thứ 3
1 2 3 đấy các bạn đóng ngoặc lại các bạn
enter đấy các bạn thấy chưa Như vậy Ở
đây mình có thành phố và điện thoại
nhưng mà cái thành phố và điện thoại nó
sẽ không tự thay đổi bây giờ mình cần
thay đổi hai cái thông số cuối cùng là
hàng và cột đúng không đấy thì để làm
việc này mình phải dùng cái hàng mét bây
giờ mình sẽ giới thiệu qua về hàng mét
nhé đấy các bạn sẽ bằng này mét các bạn
ấn Tab nhé bây Giả sử mình tìm bạn
Nguyễn Duy Dương này đúng không đấy thì
cái giá trị tìm kiếm là Nguyễn Duy Dương
phẩy mình tìm ở đâu Mình tìm ở cái phần
họ tên đây này Đấy phẩy ở đây là gì
không các bạn sẽ đóng ngoặc lại các bạn
enter ở đây Các bạn thấy chưa Nguyễn Duy
Dương nó sẽ nằm ở cái hàng thứ ba trong
cái vùng dữ liệu ở đây họ tên là một
Nguyễn Văn Ban là hai Nguyễn Duy Dương
là 3 bây giờ mình sẽ thay Nguyễn Duy
Dương bằng bằng cái Võ Quốc Việt nha các
bạn nháy chuột phải copy các bạn nhảy
các bạn tích vào đây Các bạn nhớ chuột
phải chọn paste nhé đấy các bạn thấy
chưa Như vậy cái hàng mét này nó lại trả
về số 5 ngay lập tức
này đấy các bạn chú ý cho mình là như
vậy nhé Còn nếu như cái vùng dữ liệu mà
các bạn Bôi đen ở đây mà các bạn không
có cái phần tiêu đề thì lát nữa cái hàng
mét các bạn cũng không cần phải bôi đen
cái phần tiêu đề tức là các bạn bỏ cái ô
họ tên này đi đấy Thông thường thì mình
sẽ Bôi đen cả cái tiêu đề đi Tức là mình
sẽ Bôi đen toàn bộ cái vùng dữ liệu của
mình cho nó chắc nhé Đấy phẩy Tiếp theo
là cái râu ở đây thì mình sẽ phải dùng
cái hàng mét đúng không các bạn sẽ bằng
cái hàm mét các bạn ấn Tab thì mét là
rượu Mình cần tìm cái bạn Hoàng Quốc Bảo
này đúng không phẩy trong gì trong cái
vùng dữ liệu của họ tên ở đây
đấy các bạn phải mình sẽ tìm kiếm chính
xác thì các bạn sẽ điền không ở đây cái
hàm mét thì hầu như mình tìm kiếm là tìm
kiếm chính xác hết nhá cho nên cái giá
trị cuối cùng của hàm mét là hầu như là
mình đều bằng không hết nhé Nó giống như
hàng Vlog cup ấy hầu như là mình tìm
kiếm chính xác
phẩy nhá Tiếp theo là cái cột trả về các
bạn chú ý nha cái cột trả về đây nó lại
thay đổi đúng không Lát nữa mình sẽ sửa
điện thoại bây giờ ví dụ mình muốn là gì
ạ Nếu như mà ở đây là điện thoại thì nó
sẽ trả về điện thoại nhưng mà nếu nó là
ngày tuyển dụng thì nó phải trả về ngày
tuyển dụng đấy ý là như vậy ạ Cho nên
nhớ nếu như ở đây mà các bạn cố định ví
dụ cái cột điện thoại là cột số 3 đi Ví
dụ Các bạn cứ Điền 3 vào đây đi các bạn
sẽ đóng ngoặc đơn này các bạn enter thì
nó đúng là trả về cái điện thoại của bạn
Hoàng Quốc Bảo này bây giờ ví dụ bạn
nháy chuột phải các bạn copy bạn Nguyễn
Văn Ban Nha các bạn kích vào đây các bạn
nhấn chuột phải bạn paste vào đây Đấy
thì nó cũng thay đổi nó trả về đúng điện
thoại của bạn Nguyễn Văn Ban Nhưng mà
nếu như cái điện thoại này các bạn copy
cái ngày tuyển dụng nhé các bạn copy các
bạn Vứt vào đây các bạn thay cái điện
thoại bằng gạch tuyển dụng đấy thì ở đây
nó sẽ không đúng nữa đấy thì như vậy
mình sẽ hướng dẫn các bạn là dùng cái
Index Để mình tìm được gì ạ khi mà tên
thay đổi và khi cái tiêu đề mà thay đổi
Tức là cái hạng mục mà các bạn thay đổi
thì cái kết quả nó thay đổi theo đúng
không các bạn tích đúp vào đây Thì như
vậy cái số 3 này mình cũng dùng cái hàm
mét luôn các bạn xóa cái số 3 này đi các
bạn sẽ dùng cái hàm meth đấy các bạn sẽ
ấn giữ ấn Tab thì cái giá trị mà các bạn
tìm kiếm lúc cái này là gì ạ là tìm kiếm
theo cái tiêu đề ở đây thì các bạn sẽ
tích vào cái c13 này thì lát nữa nếu như
mà ngày tuyển dụng mà mình thay bằng
điện thoại hay là lương ấy thì cái kết
quả nó cũng tự thay đổi đúng không Đấy
mình đang tìm kiếm theo Cái ô c13 này
Đấy phẩy trong cái vùng gì đấy các bạn
lại Bôi đen Cái vùng tiêu đề này cho
mình đấy thì với cái hàm mét này thì các
bạn sẽ Bôi đen cái phần tiêu đề nhá đấy
các bạn phải không đấy các bạn sẽ đóng
ngoặc đơn lại để xong cái hàm mét này
thì cái ngoặc đơn Lúc nãy ở đây là của
cái hàm index này các bạn enter đấy các
bạn thấy chưa Như vậy ngày tuyển dụng
này Bây giờ nó đang định dạng là dạng số
đúng không các bạn sẽ tích vào đây mình
sẽ đổi về cái dạng Soft hết này đấy Cái
ngày tuyển dụng là ngày 11 tháng 11 năm
2005 đây bạn Nguyễn Văn Ban này Bây giờ
mình sẽ thay bằng bạn gì ạ Bạn Hoàng
Quốc Bảo đi Các bạn nhớ chuột phải copy
Các bạn nhớ chuột phải vào đây các bạn
paste vào đây đấy các bạn thấy chưa cả
ngày tuyển dụng và thành phố đều thay
đổi theo lại rất là hay bây giờ ví dụ
mình không phải là ngày tuyển dụng nữa
mà gì là lương đi hoặc là thành phố đi
đây các bạn nháy chuột phải các bạn copy
cái thành phố các bạn Vứt vào đây
để thành phố lúc này đúng là Đà Nẵng
luôn Hoặc là lương đi
hoặc là các bạn nhớ bên phải của bạn
copy luôn các bạn nháy chuột phải vào
đây các bạn paste vào đây chứ lương nó
thay đổi nó lại chuyển về ở đây nó đang
ngày tháng đúng không các bạn chuyển về
nó là đồ đây lương của bạn Hoàng Quốc
Bảo là gì ạ Hoàng Quốc Bảo đây là 38.066
đấy Bạn thấy không rất là hay
Thì đấy là cách để mình sử dụng Index
của mét nhé Bây giờ mình sẽ xóa đi Mình
làm lại từ đầu cho các bạn dễ hiểu này
thì lúc nãy mình cứ thay và sửa rất là
nhiều Đúng không Mình sẽ xóa cái bây giờ
ví dụ mình tìm điện thoại vào thành phố
nhé Đây thành phố thì ở bên trái cái
phần họ tên đúng không còn điện thoại
thì ở bên phải đúng không các bạn nháy
chuột phải vào thành phố copy Các bạn
nhớ chuột phải vào đây bạn paste vào đây
điện thoại các bạn nhớ chuột phải copy
Các bạn nhớ chuột phải chọn paste vào
đây Đấy mình sẽ xóa cái này đi nhé Bây
giờ mình sẽ dùng công thức để mình kéo
sang đây đều được này các bạn sẽ bằng
này Đầu tiên là Index Đúng không các bạn
ấn Tab này thì thành phần đầu tiên của
Index chính là cái vùng dữ liệu các bạn
Bôi đen toàn bộ cái vùng dữ liệu ở đây
đấy các bạn sẽ ấn F4 để cố định nhé Thì
tại sao trường hợp này lại ấn F4 tại vì
mình sẽ kéo cái công thức này cho cái
phần điện thoại cho nên tất cả các vùng
tham chiếu khi mà các bạn muốn áp dụng
công thức cho các ô khác ấy thì thông
thường các cái vùng tham chiếu thì các
bạn phải cố định nó hết nhé đấy thì ở
đây mình cố định tại vì mình áp dụng cái
công thức này cho cái phần điện thoại
cho nên mình phải cố định thì lúc nãy
mình thực hành mình không cố định là vì
mình làm cho mỗi cái ô đấy thôi thì khi
mà áp dụng cho các ô khác thì các bạn
nhớ là cố định cho mình nhé phẩy tiếp
theo là gì ạ Cái râu là cái hàng trả về
đúng không các bạn sẽ dùng cái hàm mét
mét của gì của cái họ tên ở đây thì các
bạn chú ý nhá Cái bạn Hoàng Quốc Bảo này
này mình áp dụng công thức cho cái bên
này cho nên mình cũng phải cố định cái
bạn Hoàng Quốc Bảo thì các bạn phải ấn
F4 để cố định này Đấy phải mình tìm ở
đâu Mình tìm trong cái phần họ tên ở đây
riêng phần hàng nhé thì các bạn lại phải
bôi đen ở cái phần họ tên ở đây là từ C3
đến C8 thì cái này các bạn cũng ấn F4 để
cố định đi Đấy phẩy không là mình tìm
chính xác nhé các bạn đóng ngoặc đơn lại
để sang hàng mét đấy phẩy Tiếp theo là
cái cột trả về thì các bạn chú ý ở đây
thành phố phải là cột 1 còn lát nữa điện
thoại thì phải là cột số 3 đúng không
Thì ở đây mình cũng phải dùng cái hàm
mét các bạn ấn Tab nhé mét của cái tiêu
đề ở đây đấy là cái oxy 13 này thì cái
oxi 13 này các bạn không được cố định
tại vì sao khi Lát nữa mình sẽ áp dụng
công thức cho cái cột bên này cho cái
phần điện thoại thì nó phải nhảy sang
cái cột d này cho nên cái c13 các bạn
không được cố định nhé đấy các bạn phẩy
nhá các bạn làm nhiều thì các bạn sẽ
hiểu là khi nào mình cần cố định và khi
nào không cố định mình sẽ Bôi đen toàn
bộ cái vùng dữ liệu ở đây
các bạn phải ấn F4 để cố định cái vùng
dữ liệu này thì tại vì cái vùng dữ liệu
này nó luôn luôn cố định mà
phải không Mình tìm chính xác các bạn sẽ
đóng ngoặc đơn này để sang hàng mét các
bạn sẽ đóng ngoặc đơn lại để sang làm
biết Bây giờ mình sẽ enter đấy Bạn thấy
chưa Bạn Hoàng Quốc Bảo thành phố ở Đà
Nẵng bây giờ các bạn sẽ kéo công thức
này sang đây đấy các bạn thấy chưa điện
thoại của bạn Hoàng Quốc Bảo đây này Nó
có bảo đây đấy chính xác rồi nhá bây giờ
ví dụ mình thay bạn Hoàng Quốc Bảo bằng
gì ạ Bạn Hoàng bảo chị đi Các bạn nhớ
chuột phải copy hoặc bảo chị các bạn
nháy chuột phải vào đây các bạn page đấy
Bạn thấy chưa cả thành phố và số điện
thoại đã thay đổi theo đấy mình dùng
Index vào Messenger không rất là hay cái
hàm index vào mét này nó sẽ khắc phục
được cái nhược điểm của hàm Vlookup là
không tìm được ở bên trái nhé Thì ngoài
ra khi bạn chèn thêm một hàng hay một
cột nó đều không thay đổi ví dụ ở đây
nhé các bạn nháy chuột phải các bạn
Insert một cái hàng nữa đi Các bạn thấy
chưa cái kết quả thành phố và điện thoại
nó đều không thay đổi trong khi cái hàm
Vlookup mà cái cột trả về các bạn cố
định thì nó sẽ bị sai luôn đấy Đấy cũng
là một cái ưu điểm của cái Index vàng
mét nữa Bây giờ mình sẽ Bách lại
Ok Bây giờ mình sẽ xem cái câu hỏi về
nhà cho cái bài tập ngày hôm nay nhé
các bạn tích vào cái phần câu hỏi này
đấy thì ok Đây là cái bài tập về nhà nhé
Ở đây nó có rất là nhiều sheet đầu tiên
là cái ứng dụng của cái hàm Today để các
bạn sẽ tính gì ạ Tính ngày hôm nay số
tháng và số 5 dựa vào cái ngày vào làm ở
đây
tiếp theo là cái hàm Sum Ví dụ mình có
doanh số rồi tính tổng như thế nào hàm
đây là hàm tính trung bình nhé Đây là
hàm đếm này hàm If hàm O và Vlog cấp đấy
thì đây là bài tập về nhà cho các bạn
nhé Thì ở đây riêng cái hàm If này thì
bạn chú ý cho mình nhé cái mục tiêu ở
đây là gì ạ mục tiêu ở đây là cái ô này
đấy thì nếu như mà Bạn nào đạt kế hoạch
tức là nó lớn hơn mục tiêu thì các bạn
sẽ ghi Đạt Còn nếu như mà không thì các
bạn sẽ ghi là không đạt nhé đấy Cái ô
này nó sẽ thay đổi nhá Nếu như mà là 60
thì các bạn Kết quả nó cũng phải thay
đổi theo tức là nó sẽ thay đổi theo cái
giá trị mà các bạn Nhập vào đây đấy là
cái hàm If nhé Bài về Nếu các bạn là như
vậy
các bạn chú ý nhé mình sẽ để cái phần
link tải file thực hành của cái bài tập
ngày hôm nay cùng với cả câu hỏi trong
cái phần mô tả phía dưới video nếu như
bạn nào mà không biết cách tải về thì
các bạn sẽ xem lại cái bài đầu tiên
trong bài đấy mình đã hướng dẫn các bạn
chi tiết là cách các bạn tải về rồi ạ
Đấy
Ok như vậy là mình đã kết thúc bài học
ngày hôm nay ở đây cảm ơn các bạn đã
theo dõi các bạn nhớ đăng ký Kênh để cập
nhật video mới nhất của gà cũng như chia
sẻ để giúp mọi người cùng học Excel nhé
Xin chào và hẹn gặp lại
[âm nhạc]